-It doesn't get much cooler
than Eric Idle.
Yes. No, you. Exactly. Yes.
-Oh, okay. Fine. I'm cold.
-No.
-I'm so cool, I'm cold.
-You are so cool, you're cold.
Oh, my gosh.
We got to talk
a little bit backstage.
First of all, thank you
for coming back on the show.
You know you're one of my
favorite humans of all time.
You're one of my favorite
comedians of all time.
I love you.
I absolutely love you.
-Oh, well, thank you very much.
Thank you very much..
-It means a lot
that you're here.
-I don't think comedians
are humans,
but, I mean, you know,
I appreciate what you're saying.
-But you were telling me
that you learned a lot
about your ancestry.
-Yes.
I've been studying my ancestry.
And I did that thing
called ancestry.com.
-Yeah.
-And it was very interesting,
because I found out --
I didn't know and I found out
that I was 39,942,003rd in line
to the British throne.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So if something happens
to 39,931,000, accident --
you know,
accidents can happen.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's interesting.
-I will be king.
-Oh, my gosh!
Basically, we have
royalty on the show.
-Exactly.
-Oh, I'm so excited.
Well, who knows? Yeah.
I want to talk to you
about Spamalot, though.
Congratulations.
It is back on Broadway.
This is a big deal.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The original
Broadway production,
this won three Tonys,
including Best Musical.
-Best Musical, yeah.
-And it is one of the
funniest plays I've ever seen.
But before "Spamalot,"
weirdly enough --
I did a little research here
and found out you were
once nominated for a Tony?
-Yes, a long time ago,
I used to --
I lived in England, in London,
and I got an envelope
in the mail one day.
And I opened it.
A big, beautiful envelope.
And it said, "Congratulations!
You have been nominated
for Best Actress on Broadway."
And I'd never been to Broadway
or even America.
But so I wrote back and said,
"This is very moving for me.
I'm very honored, because, 'A,'
I've not been on Broadway,
and 'B,'
I'm not really an actress.
I have worn women's clothing
on television from time to time,
but not really an actress."
And, so, I accepted,
and then I never heard any more.
And it turned out
it was for Chita Rivera.
-What?!
-Well, how do you send it to
London to Chita Rivera?
You know?
Anyway, so, I was that close
to being in the remake
of "West Side Story."
-Oh, that's not true.
That's not -- Okay.
Come on.
-Yeah.
-"Spamalot"
is based on the movie
"Monty Python
and the Holy Grail."
-It is.
-And it's
very, very, very funny.
You actually put it up
in Washington recently,
at the Kennedy Center,
and it just destroyed.
It crushed.
-The Washington critic said,
"It's not fair
to make me laugh this much,"
which I like that as a review.
That's quite nice, isn't it?
-Yeah, that is a great --
So, is that the reason why
you're bringing it
back to Broadway?
-They wanted to bring it.
It's a Kennedy Center
production.
And we put some more people
in from "SNL"
and very good casting people.
And, yeah, I'm looking for--
I haven't actually seen it,
so I'm going to go
and see it soon, shortly.
-Yeah, the voice of God --
-Yes. No, we've had
a problem with that,
because the voice of God
is there,
and last time
we were on Broadway,
John Cleese played God.
You know, obviously.
[ Applause ]
And now -- But, you know,
now, you know,
he's getting on a bit.
He's getting up there.
And, also, you know, I mean,
John's gone a bit strange,
you know.
I mean, remember he threw
water over me on your show?
-Yeah, we got in trouble.
-Right here.
And you don't want God
who throws water
over people, you know, do you?
I mean, Moses says,
"Hello, God,"
and he throws
a bucket of water over him?
-Yeah, you don't want that.
-Apart from now
he's a burning bush.
You know, they're going
to put him out.
So we fired him.
-Yes. Fired John Cleese.
-And I played him
for a little while.
I was playing God,
and then I fired myself
because I wasn't very good.
-Yeah, what'd that feel like?
-Well, it was quite good,
actually.
I quite enjoyed firing myself.
-Yeah.
Are you still in a good
relationship with yourself?
-Eh, I'm not
talking to me, really?
But apart from that...
-I wouldn't talk to you
either -- if I were you.
-So, anyway,
we found somebody else,
and I can announce it tonight
because he said I can.
And God is going to be
played by Steve Martin.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's fantastic.
God will be played
by Steve Martin.
And then I want you to come back
on after you fire him.
-Okay.
-I'm so excited you're here.
Everyone go see "Spamalot."
Eric Idle, everyone.
"Spamalot" is back on Broadway.
Go see Steve Martin as God
at the St. James Theatre.
Rick Ross and Meek Mill
perform for us after the break.
Stick around, everybody.